this morning I spoke with Prime Minister  Netanyahu of Israel about the situation  in Gaza we discussed Israel's military  operation in Gaza including its efforts  to stop the threat of terrorist  infiltration through tunnels into Israel  I reaffirmed my strong support for  Israel's right to defend itself no  nation should accept rockets being fired  into its borders or terrorists tunneling  into its territory in fact while I was  having the conversation with Prime  Minister Netanyahu sirens went off in  Tel Aviv I also made clear that the  United States and our friends and allies  are deeply concerned about the risks of  further escalation and the loss of more  innocent life